Film Courage: How do you feel on those days
when you have no time to work on your writing?
West Liang: I get really depressed.
I get depressed…I get self-defeating.
I’ve always believed about the parable of
the Tortoise and the Hare.
I feel like I’m like the tortoise (kind
of).
I have a really strong, present work ethic,
that sometimes gets really annoying.
So I have a really bad guilty conscious about
not working.
So there are certain days where I am not doing
any writing or not doing any workshopping
and it’s frustrating because you feel like
you’re not productive.
But I think going back to a bigger kind of
frame, I think those moments are important
when I do experience writer’s block.
I go for a hike and zone out and I spend a
day at the beach or I am watching a movie
or something.
I think a lot of good can come from that.
It gives you perspective and distance from
the project a little bit and I also think
if you are not writing because there is something
wrong with the script (the story) or that
something else is supposed to happen that
you have to think whether it is life things
or whether it’s whatever.
So I try not to beat myself up too much about
it.
But I can be very hard on myself, for sure.
Film Courage: Really…that’s interesting.
I see that you’d be more easy on yourself.
West Liang: What we are in this business (so
many of us) we’re not treated as business
owners, we’re not treated as entrepreneurs.
We treated as struggling artists.
But we are business owners.
We each are running our own business with
limited staff, with high overhead, with trying
to figure out how to make our product different
from competitors.
And we’re all struggling to find funding.
We have to kind of wear that hat with a little
more pride.
We are business owners and entrepreneurs.
And so it is tough for people because you
feel like you’re not going to work on that
one day.
You feel like “Oh no.
What’s going on?”
I think it’s tough when I feel like I am
not being productive.
Film Courage: Do you recognize that when you’re
in the moment of that [feeling]?
Let’s suppose you have a week coming up
where you’re really not going to have time.
And you know that and you’re like “Okay…I’m
just going to bite the bullet and do what
I am going to have to do.”
Do you start to recognize it in yourself and
go “Oh, gosh…you know what it is [why
I feel so badly]?
It’s because I’m not working on my creative
stuff.”
West Liang: I’ve read a lot of blogs and
watched a lot of interviews with other writers
who either have the luxury to write every
single day because they are being paid to
write a certain script or that’s how they
work.
But I think for me, I’m not sure I’m the
kind of writer who writes every day.
Maybe I need to be a little bit better about
that.
But I try to be mindful of what is inspiring
to me at the moment and letting that energy
build up so I’m not just sitting at a computer
staring at a blank page.
For me I think sometimes it’s important
to stare at a blank page and other times it’s
really important to just let that energy build
up, build up, and build up so that
you have a lot to say and to express and you
put it all on the page.
I think that is important.